-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ "Hashtags" ♪
♪ "Hashtags" ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week where
I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So, since summer
is starting to wind down,
I asked you to describe
your summer using the hashtag
"#MySummerInSixWords."
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
We do it every week,
so thank you.
And now I thought
I'd share some of
my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@JakeWilliamsArt.
He says...
This one's from @dlandes7577.
This next one is from
@kyledice23.
He says...
-Yeah.
-That's not bad.
-It's like an Ironman.
-This one's from
@MultiverseSnob.
She says...
They are too big for --
I don't know.
This one is from, actually,
Dan Rather.
-Oh.
-Legend. He says...
This one is from @risaines1.
She says...
This one is from @LuckyGuy2017.
He says...
That sums up their summer
in six words.
This one's from @kepbarnett.
She says...
-Ooh!
-That sounds like
the song of the summer.
Yeah, I like that.
-That's the song of the summer.
-This one is from @SunnyMFLynn.
She says...
This one is from @BobPoulter.
He is the father of Olympic
athlete Jordyn Poulter.
He says...
-Oh!
-There you go.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty awesome.
-Come on!
-That's a good summer.
"My daughter won a gold medal."
-Yeah.
-Congratulations, Jordyn.
-Add White Claw to that,
and you're good.
-This one is from @trillo carl.
He says...
This one is from @ReneeJordan78.
She says...
This last one is from
@BenPack3521.
He says...
-Ah!
-There you have it.
Thank you, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Ben Pack.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.